du haut de la butte montmartre le
sacré-coeur domine paris au lieu du
tourisme hexagonal le quartier accueille
pas moins de 10 millions de touristes
par an attiré par un décor de carte
postale entre rues pavées restaurants
traditionnels et patrimoine artistique
qui ont fait sa renommée
mais cet été ça ne se bouscule pas la
butte semble faire grise mine
boudé par des millions de visiteurs
venus d'ordinaire des quatre coins du
monde
conséquence directe de la crise du
coronavirus le village semble figée et
son économie bouleversé à quelques pas
de la place du tertre al din qui
accouchent n'aurais jamais pensé un jour
vivre un tel scénario de clients c'est
des français qui repasse on a 20 % de
remplissage en fait surtout le sur toute
la période
on l'a on n'a pas de on n'a pas du tout
2 d'entrée d'argent vraiment en
conséquence en fait c'est un peu
catastrophique
ces matches là sont ces tests étaient
prévus en temps normal l'hôtel affiche
un taux de remplissage de 75 à 80%
un hôtel vide c'est un manque à gagner
considérable au lourd de conséquences
les banquiers ont été compréhensifs
par contre les propriétaires ils n'ont
pas d'autres moyens que nous nous
demander de payer notre loyer qui est
quand même assez conséquent les
assurances elles veulent pas entendre
parce que sont très très bien protégé à
montmartre il n'y a pas que les hôtels
qui sont vides les terrasses de
restaurants elles aussi sont moins de
faire le plein stéphane désespère de
voir ces tables vides
d'habitude à cette heure-là il est dans
le rush mais cette année il est obligé
d'aller à la chasse aux clients bonjour
comme ses voisins il s'appuie
d'ordinaire sur une clientèle à 80%
étrangères mais avec le co vide
les clients sont majoritairement
français est moins dépensiers c'est
vraiment compliqué en ce moment soit 30
ouvert aujourd'hui sinon c'est 150
couverts un jour à des sons convergent
sur une italie sans comme ça on est 14
et là autant de l'a4 au nez à -90 % de
chiffre d'affaires qu'il soit assis ou
en vadrouille les 300 artistes de
montmartre font la notoriété de la place
du tertre d'ordinaire habitué à
enchaîner les croquis cette année c'est
au petit bonheur la chance
beaucoup n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
se brader pour s'en sortir
pour gilles un des plus anciens du
village ce jeune homme sera l'un de ses
seuls clients de la journée je viens
faire des portraits de cabine selon
celle que de la peinture et la peinture
savoir pratiquement pas en ce moment est
venu compliquer pour vous de travailler
cette année
oui on en gagne le coeur à peine par
rapport à l'an dernier aux autres années
dans légal dans les galeries
les touristes étrangers qui viennent de
loin c'est eux qui payent
mais là ils viennent par an les
canadiens cet excellent client bon en ce
moment on a des allemands quelques
suisses des belges des néerlandais
c'est tout
depuis l'incendié de notre dame de paris
montmartre est le site le plus visité de
la capitale mais aussi un des plus
touchés par la crise du coronavirus
première destination touristique au
monde
la france affiche cette année un bilan
catastrophique conséquence de la crise
des pertes anticipées de 7 à 9 milliards
d'euros sont à prévoir pour le seul
premier trimestre pas de quoi rassurer
les acteurs du secteur touristique